so I'm going to talk about Geo body for
those of you who aren't familiar with
as Chris said Drouin up by this the Thai
writer Tong Chatwin a shackle and he
defined it a nation's territory is not
simply a sizable piece of the Earth's
surface
it's a territoriality it's a source of
pride loyalty love passion bias hatred
reason and unreason it also generates
many other conceptions and practices
about a nation hood as it combines with
other elements of nationhood so other
writers have already applied the concept
of the Jia body to China
Robert Kulp used it to argue that
Chinese school geography and history
textbooks in the 1930s this his quote
worked together to produce an image of
the Chinese nation as a Jia body they
formulated an image of China as a
cohesive territorial unit with fixed
boundaries and unified sovereignty they
sought to naturalize China's territorial
unity by projecting it backwards into
the deep historical past and in some
cases by associating arbitrary political
borders with seemingly natural
boundaries which is what Kris was just
talking about the rhetorical and
symbolic construction of China was a
bounded and sovereign territory helped
to underwrite the perceived need to
reclaim territory deemed to have been
lost to imperialist powers and to
integrate bordering areas of
questionable sovereignty into the
centralized politics that's what cold
says school textbooks in China of trying
to do in the 1930s William Callahan has
looked at the ways that cartography
became a means of describing China's
national humiliation at the hands of
imperialist powers and then a mechanized
mechanism for mobilizing the population
against those powers now these three
writers have worked almost entirely on
land issues but I think the similar
processes were under way in connection
with the South China Sea
and what seems clear to me from looking
at some of the sources is that China's
maritime geo body it's emotional
attachment to the islands in the South
China Sea emerged in a few distinct
episodes so there was an initial burst
in 1907 to 1909 initially focused on the
island of paratus and then the Paracels
second burst in 1933 following Frances
annexation of six of the Spratly Islands
and then the third episode in 1940 67
which Chris has written his excellent
paper about and it's not one single
simple process but several intertwined
processes so the reactions the
predations of the imperial powers as it
discussed at the failure of the Ching
Imperial authorities to resist those
predations the chings attempts to
bolster their legitimacy and then
Chinese elites attempts to integrate
themselves with the modern world which
involved changing concepts of what China
is and what it means to be Chinese
so 1907 it was an extremely turbulent
year in southern China that decaying
decay to the ching the loss of charity
to japan in 1894 v and the international
invasion to cross the box or bid Boxer
Rebellion a few years before and in
parallel with the rise of the republican
movement southern China is in political
ferment a large number of civic
organizations emerge to voice popular
anger against both the imperial powers
and the failure of the Ching and there
were least five nationalist uprisings
against the Qing in Guangdong and
Guangxi province is that year one of the
generals most actively involved in
putting down these uprisings was a
figure called Legion who was then the
brigade general in the Far East of
Guangdong province for some reason and
I'm still not sure entirely why in
spring of 1907 he decides to visit the
island of Pratt's which lies
approximately halfway between Hong Kong
and Taiwan it's not clear why is in his
own account which I think was published
a year later but even that am i entirely
sure when he was published he says he
just heard fishermen in his County say
that if you want to get rich head for
the dong show the practice the eastern
sands when he gets there he discovers
the islands is already occupied by a
Japanese entrepreneur this is our
yoshiji and a hundred laborers working
the guano deposits digging up bird [ __ ]
basically to sell for fertilizer back
home so the Admiral is shot yoshiji
tells Lee that he had discovered the
islands 18 months before and since it
was unoccupied claimed it for Japan the
Admiral then encounters a fisherman old
man Yu who tells him about some other
rich Islands just 200 leaves south of
Hainan which Westerners are called the
pyla soon he heads there according to
his account quotes because these islands
belong to China although he's never
actually heard of them what he found in
Paracels appears to have led him to then
recommend an official expedition to
settle the islands to prevent other
foreigners occupying them at the same
time he writes an emotive account of his
1907 voyage including his confrontation
with the Oh Shi Jie which i think is
published in earth
Scientist magazine in 1908 although the
indexes say that that magazine didn't
start publishing until 1910 so I'm so
trying to work out when that was
actually published and then Wang dong
province establishes a commission for
the management for Paracels sometime in
1908 now all this is taking place at a
time of growing anger about foreign
activities in China so in 1907 there was
anger about planned British anti-piracy
patrols on the West River between Hong
Kong and Canton going to and the crisis
is resolved early in 1908 when the
governor-general of the two provinces of
Guangdong Guangxi appoints the same
Admiral de Jong as the provincial naval
commander with a mission to end piracy
on the river and this is seen as a great
victory for the nationalist cause in
February March 1908 20,000 people took
part in protests against Japan's
reaction to the seizure by the Chinese
authorities of a Japanese freighter and
this led to members of the
self-government Society account on
merchant society calling for action to
recover from the national humiliation of
the episode and this phrase national
humiliation takes root at this point
there were national humiliation meetings
one attended by thousands and thousands
of women according to local press
reports where they urge everyone to wear
a ring engraved with the phrase national
humiliation and a society to commemorate
national humiliation is formed in
Gwangju around the same time so perhaps
this is why the guangdong authorities
put such efforts into their efforts to
claim the Paracels the South China
Morning Post of the 16th of March 1909
notes that quotes the local Chinese mind
has been agitated somewhat by the
reports from practice and that the
Chinese and the South are not taking the
matter kindly and then it says that the
governor had actually imposed press
censorship on the on the local papers to
stop them making inflammatory comments
about the issue but at the end of this
of March 1908 the governor-general's
expedition goes to the Paracels a sort
of reconnaissance thing and brings back
some big turtles which apparently caused
a huge sensation in Hong Kong and
southern China and then this is followed
by a very high-ranking delegation indeed
which include the Admiral the Delta the
secretary of the five provinces finance
department and the
commissioner and they have grand plans
as to how they're going to develop the
Paracels and make them you know a kind
of a money-making venture for for
southern China but the point is they
don't know what the way they're going to
and when they get there they have a
terrible visit their voyage is delayed
by typhoons they only get to spend two
days in there and it seems they're
utterly disappointed by what they find
on the Paracels and a short time after
we're here the only plan for the islands
is perhaps it could become a convict
colony so the idea of how they were
going to make vast amounts of money on
other Power Cells disappears nonetheless
this is the point at which you know we
see for the first time a an act of state
sovereignty by the Chinese by part of
the Chinese state over the praticed
islands in June 1909 but there's still
anger about a Nishizawa
on practice he's still mining that the
guano there so there's a boycott of
Japanese goods organised in southern
China and eventually there were
negotiations and the content there the
guangdong authorities completion
agreement they pain she's our a hundred
and thirty thousand silver dollars to
abandon his workings and the japanese
government agrees to recognize China's
claim to practice so this on the
evidence available appears to be the
first moment that Chinese public opinion
takes an interest in the sovereignty of
the South China Sea Islands and at this
point the the Guangdong Administration
deploys documents showing that the
islands have long been used by Chinese
fishermen even if the Chinese state had
never actually heard of them before
now what strikes me when you read these
articles is how familiar the
english-language authors expect readers
to be with the Paracels because they are
people who go backwards and forces in
Hong Kong and Singapore they've sailed
past these islands they know where they
are they know they're notorious as a
hazard to shipping and as a haven for
pirates and you can trust that with the
lack of knowledge in the inner Chinese
sources that kind of brings so at the
end of the episode really is when
praticed Island is purchased and there's
been this mission to the Paracels from
the grind on authorities but nothing
really much happens after that
everything
grandiose plans to develop the islands
but but nothing really happens at least
for not for nothing other 20 years or so
nineteen eleven of course as the
Revolution in China 1912 Sun yat-sen is
kicked out of power by Yuan Shikai and
sets up a rival government shortly
afterwards in Guangzhou and from this
point on there's pretty much there were
different regimes between you know
what's happening in Beijing or Nanjing
and the South to kind of cut a long
story short in the night early in the
1920s that the French authorities in a
nom start and the and they you know what
would become the vietnamese authorities
start to take an interest in the islands
and Jared sequester's written an
excellent paper about how it was
actually the oceanographic institution
the self-interest of the the marine
biologists in Indochina which plays an
important role in actually trying to
assert a French claim to some of the
islands but yeah it starts that the
French starts are moving in in the late
1920s
in response the Guangdong province puts
the Paracels under the administration of
Sun yat-sen University and they organize
a mission so it's starting to get a bit
more contented and contested in the
Paracels in the late 1920s in an effort
to try to regularize the maps of China
the the new Chinese government in 1930
passes some regulations to inspect maps
to try to regularize them which is more
than regular maizing maps it's actually
really about defining the country's
boundaries on land but also on water and
at the same time you've got the Japanese
or shortly after you have the Japanese
invading the Northeast and so everything
things like that this committee are put
on hold at the same time the KMT splits
and you have a southern faction that
breaks away and so they're acting
autonomously from the government in in
in Nanjing so in effect they are
nominally part of the same regime acting
autonomously and in 1932 there are
exchanges between France and China about
who owns the Paracels
once again and I want this as a
coincidence is that in June 1933 this
inspection
Miche Philander water maps finally
starts to meet two years after it was
officially set up and they begin the
process of actually defining the
country's boundaries and trying to
regularize the maps this is a state
process but at the same time the French
are thinking about annexing the Spratly
Islands and as far as I can see this is
these things are coincidental one
doesn't happen because of the other now
the background to the annexation of the
six the Spratlys by France has been
examined by a few other authors but to
simplify it the story is that on the
13th of April 1930 the French warship
Melissa Sears took possession on behalf
of France of Spratly Island and quote
other islands depending on it without
naming them but the French authorities
failed to formally publicize the
annexation although news did was printed
in a few newspapers then three years
later prompted by an inquiry from the
British government France
Rianne axes Spratly Island plus five
others by name and borne a key into a
beurre North danger reef known in French
as leaders ut2 and the waiter between
the 7th and 12th of April news of the
annexation is released on Bastille Day
14th of July 1933 reported in some
French newspapers and a formal
announcement is printed in the state's
Journal officiel on the 25th of July for
some reason as a mistake they then
reprinted the following day on the 26th
of July we can trace the Chinese
reaction to the annexation through
reports in the Shanghai based Chinese
language newspaper Chen Bao and the
South China Morning Post in English and
what's important to note is a very
confused reaction with significant
differences between the central
government in Nanjing and the
southwestern government in Guangzhou and
between officials and popular
organizations so Chen Bao carries the
Bastille Day announcement with reports
from correspondents in Paris and Manila
and London they note the latitude and
longitude of the islands as announced by
the French government and that they're
located somewhere between Saigon and the
Philippines they also point out the
presence of Chinese fishermen on the
islands now the following day
Chen Bao reports the Chinese foreign
ministry is trying to find out more
about the situation and reports a couple
of days later the foreign ministry has
asked the Chinese consulate in Manila to
report on the situation now according to
American records the Chinese consul
Manila Quang Quang wing sighted Quang
Quang Ling visits the American coast and
geodetic Survey office in Manila on the
26th of July and discovers with surprise
that the Spratly Islands and the Paracel
Islands are different the following day
while he's still were parting his report
the Shen bow reports that the foreign
ministry in China is preparing to
protest the French government and has
asked the French so the Chinese embassy
in France for more information so it's
clear there's confusion about where the
islands are with the French have annexed
an article in the north China how orbit
is the principal english-language
newspaper in China in this period they
reports that the annexed islands are
quotes known as the seashell group the
Paracels and on the 28th it says that
Nanjing correspondent so shambo's
Nanjing correspondent reports of the ROC
government suspects that the NX islands
are in the Paracels they then start
printing material from the 1928
University expedition on the Paracels
it's a kind of assert a Chinese claim
ineffective as practice yeah there's a
mixing the two uh but this clear
confusion but this confusion at least in
the eyes of the central government in
Nanjing is quickly clarified but by then
there's already being a popular reaction
to the failure of the French government
so I thought the Qing government the
Republic government to respond to the
French annexation they're already
protests in the newspapers complaints
demonstrations from members of the
Hainan society in Beijing and things
like this so by by the first of August
so two weeks after the the announcement
the central government is fairly clear
that these islands are a power are the
Spratlys and not the Paracels and to cut
a long story short and I have quite a
long story here it comes down to a
meeting of the ROC s Military Committee
in the 1st of September a secret meeting
at which they decide that they have no
claim that China has no claim to the
Spratly Islands and they're agitated
about it they say we know our fishermen
go there but we have
no evidence that we've ever made a claim
and this is quite different from the the
southwestern authorities who I think are
unaware of this meeting of the military
committee and continue to agitate about
the fate of the Paracels and continue to
mix the idea that what the French have
annexed is in the Paracels and they say
they continue to be confused about
exactly that so and the Southwest
province used this issue as a means to
attack the national nationalist
legitimacy of the government and Nanjing
have already been accused of being too
soft on the Japanese of selling out the
country and that they are the pure you
know hardline representatives of proper
China and they use this issue to attack
to attack Nanjing so it's in their
interests to keep stoking up the claim
and they deliberately deliberately or
unwittingly confuse Paracels and
Spratlys
at this point and what happens really is
that aren't shortly after this a series
of articles are printed in Chinese
newspapers trying to explain the history
of the South China Sea Islands not to
foreigners not to sort of assert a claim
to the French or the British or the
Japanese or anybody but to their own
people so this is what we talk about
many of the construction of the G of
what he trying to generate a narrative
in which Chinese people can understand
that they have always owned these
islands and always always been the
rightful owners by picking out
references going back to 1928 going back
to the the Admirals expedition of 1909
and he he gives an interview in August
1983 talking about his his old his old
voyage and Jenner and helps to generate
a national narrative you like about the
connection between the islands and the
mainland and what's fascinating to me
and I came to this the other way because
I was trying to trace the references
which are being used in English now and
where those sources and references come
from and it's clear to me that the first
very first english-language writing
about the South China Sea dispute only
happens in 1975 after the battle the
Paracels the previous year and they're
written by in the
international lawyers who usually have a
background in China so paper by hunger
Chu and Chandra Park - was from Taiwan
but nothing but tau Chang he was here at
the LLM at Peking University and they
are using their original sources are
these newspapers and magazines which are
published in August September October of
1933 and I could list them if you want
but there are about you know six
articles which define the Chinese
narrative and it's connection to the
South China Sea Islands and they are
then picked up and quoted and we quoted
for the next 80 or 90 years before they
are then last for so 40 years to 1775
they continued to be quoted in Chinese
and they have now performed the
foundation of a lots of the English
language writing about the South China
Sea dispute and that narrative is the
narrative you find in Marwan Samuels
book on the South China Sea disputes
it's the narrative you find in mark
Valencia's writing about the search
honesty disputes and it all comes back
to a few badly informed newspaper
articles published in the summer of 1933